Lieutenant Tom hudner Jesse Brown It's  good to meet you Jesse Brown pulled  himself up from his bootstraps and put  himself in the sky you belonged in the  sky Jesse remember you belong down here  with okay Jesse Brown's story is one of  the most heroic and important stories in  Naval History pretty slick flying just  trying to keep it interesting how have I  not heard this story before the  commanding officer called you one of the  best Pilots he's ever seen to become the  first African-American Naval aviator it  must be hard being the Naval aviator  absolutely he's had to work harder than  just about anyone can't tell you how  many times people have told me to give  up quit that I even Jesse aggressively  went after things that seemed impossible  I could hit the bridge and he did that  with sacrifice and devotion for his  family for his country and for his own  self-worth  science that's in  [Music]